the tekken action does not stop here the
tekken online challenge 2021 japan
online masters we got geese versus
goneri we got chichron versus uh karee
so let's start this off markman
you thought we were on break i'm
actually doing commentary from the
bathroom right now this is going to be
exciting
so let's find out now again
man this this astro headset is so good
it reaches all the way to my restroom
man i can't wait to see this scan with
you this gan ryu is is is so sick
let's see how he's able to deal with
chicken and his geese because you know
geese is one of those characters that is
so good at kind of threading the needle
with a lot of his pokes and
you know ganryu doesn't have the
quickest attacks but his ability to kind
of create space using things like down
four two from a certain range that i
think is going to be the key for him to
kind of break down the offense or the
defense of chicorin
yeah and just the conditioning right
down four three down four three then
he's gonna in that down forward too
chicory now does have some rage to work
with but you know what carrie on the gas
here not allowing it oh he jumps in on
him mark man
good stuff that opening round very
important way to kind of get a feel of
uh of the match-up and right now you
could tell gandhi you or kadri i should
say is prepared for this geese match-up
he is yeah it's it's showing so let's
see if he'll be able to take uh some of
these rounds off of
chicago building that bar and now
introdu trying to introduce carrie to
that wall always going to float him to
the wall
nice big combo
big life deficit early on here
kari's going to have his work cut out
for him how is he gonna react how is he
gonna get down twos are you serious he's
pulling out all the moves
yeah
he's gonna use all the moves he paid for
the entire game he's gonna use
everything now we see the checker and
though in the life deficit trying to get
that throw going but watch out for that
back three two
oh he got clapped up though
he should be able to close it out here
good stuff
yeah it's all business with his outfit
curry
this is like a business
with geese yeah
he's like uh so i'll meet you for our
two o'clock at the top of the mishima
building
we could squeeze in a few yeah we could
throw hands on the way up there and then
we see that uh genre you know oh my god
hundred hand slap
chicarin has two meters to work with can
he burn the meter in time oh oh gets the
splat
collecting some damage here but tyre's
still looking pretty healthy
oh he has double double jabs too soon
oh my god oh the backswing blow
whoa
check her into the air fireball yeah get
that out of here
that was crazy why would you go for the
backswing vote maybe he do he probably
knows something that i don't but man
that was crazy that was a huge risk i
kind of just threw it away
and chickering right now between all of
that just built so much meter he's close
to two meters here how is kari going to
catch up here
oh my god is kyrie going to catch up
check her in with that down through wake
up now we see that yeah chickering
collecting some huge dividends from that
wake up low
harry has to play his cards right he
can't be too reckless approaching
[Music]
backing away
two lands
yo
whoa we're going the other way
there we are
kyrie working on a comeback here
chickering just needs to land one clean
hit can he get it final seconds of this
round
trying to zone him out clap a little too
short oh it just goes for the legs
clean stuff i like what i'm seeing here
the way that chicory is really
approaching the matchup it's not putting
a lot of gaps in in offensively and
khari has to really really work for the
damage that he's trying to get out of
this and again that's an uphill battle i
think it's so hard to kind of penetrate
your opponent's defense with ganryu you
have to kind of rely on certain things
like you know using down forward three
at the tip and then forcing your
opponent to react and trying to
capitalize off of that you have to like
do a lot of spacing tricks to make
things happen uh to get a clean hit on
them and it's not easy it's definitely
not easy
yeah especially going against chicorin
we did say that karee seemed comfortable
in the geese match look early on but
towards like the final rounds of that
match you just saw how chicken was able
to find you know ways to get around the
low he jumped the low and just uh
got the the dive kick and we saw that he
was able to just really manage the range
and and not even allow um uh carry to
even get in so yeah kyrie's gonna have
to do some adjusting here on out
absolutely and
um i'm trying to think like in my head
like what can he do in the matchup i
mean obviously anything that he goes for
like in terms of like you know
putting pressure on his opponent is
going to probably bring more risk and
you know checker and the way he plays
it's like he's a wall
he's always been like a wall in the
style that he plays so i i feel like
again he's he's going to have his work
cut out for him i think it's going to be
one of those situations where there's
going to be a lot of trades there's
going to be certain scrambles and
whoever really clutches it out and comes
out on top that's going to get that and
take it to the the round level and
eventually the match level but right now
we're going into the twilight conflict
which is the stage of choice here for
karne
and we seem to be selling a lot of these
bouts in twilight conflict so let's see
if this will uh pay dividends for karee
and yes yeah gets the sumo throw throw
him down
oh my god harry
he knew
he did chicken scene to the future again
stops the low option finds the opening
thankfully for kyrie didn't have a bar
to spend now he does
okay
one one two to close it out round two
chicarin had two huge reads there he
knew when to do the parry he knew when
to do the jumping this guy has a read on
the matchup look at this while standing
wow
dude he's so good
yeah now what are you gonna do he reads
here and it's been paying off uh oh yeah
he's able to get out of that situation
and see though chicorin has been making
these huge reads and it's been paying
off so well for him carrying out just
backing away trying to create some
distance clap gets blocked and now check
her in
still trying to find his opening he's
not going for anything too crazy just
yet now has two meters jumps in again
he baited him for that too he knew at
that exact moment once he did the
running one that his opponent would try
to react with some type of blow and he
got the jump in on him so clean
nice punish
yeah okay nice df2 here carry catching a
break here and gets the balcony break
collect some huge damage
reads are still on point
he went for the big sumo bomb there but
wasn't able to get it but look he has a
huge lively he almost died right there
he almost died to that jumping
because he has two meters in range that
would have been brutal round four it
would have been so yeah carry you know
just getting that round just by just a
little bit chicory is still very much in
this match
especially with full meter now
how you can deal with it we might see
something brilliant here i mean he has
three meters only good only good things
could come out of three meter combos
oh if you're using that geese but carrie
has to be very careful okay rising
punish there
catches a break here pushes for the wall
and still keeping you know things real
close quarters here
see what he does here again having to
deal with all this meter is it has to be
in your mind here that you're going to
have to change it up
oh my god he's he's going for the lead
nice
he just needs that one big jump in
though but carrie
tries to jump in on him
final seconds mark man how is carrie
gonna close this one out he's trying to
run away with it
oh my god he almost found an opening
there final seconds oh he got it enough
oh he went for the title but it was
enough
wow
that was the last hit at the very end
he he was able to beat him on time man
that uh that chickering guy is really
good that chicory guy is really good and
you know
going into this we saw how strong karee
was especially in his prior matchup when
he played against taiheil but chikarin
on a different level from what we've
seen so far he definitely controlled
that and
of course he's gonna move on man he is
he's good that boy is good
yeah who's this chickering